buongiorno a tutti grazie per questo
corto il che mi chiamo paolo proserpio e
vorrei cominciare con una domanda che
cos'è questo
no mi dispiace ma questi non sono propri
corn questa è la grande nuova truffa del
rock'n'roll
sono nato nel 1977 è la mia prima
esperienza fisica legata alla musica
e questo un disco che i miei genitori
suonavano in uno stereo con due casse
che pesano come nella mia nipotina da e
uno è un giradischi che pesa all'incirca
5 kg
all'interno di questa copertina c'è un
disco che sembra una pizza nera che
girando sul giradischi produce la musica
dopo quell'esperienza mi sono continuate
ad appassionare di musica grazie
soprattutto allo skate che è stata una
mia grandissima passione è la musica da
allora si è evoluta si è trasformata
diventando una cassetta
poi diventata un cd poi è diventato un
file da scaricare legalmente o
illegalmente
poi questi file sono addirittura spariti
perché sono due sono arrivate le
piattaforme musicali
il mio lavoro coincide esattamente con
la mia passione perché mi occupo di dare
una veste una fisicità a questa musica
che ormai non esiste più
l'enorme differenza che c'è tra adesso e
quando ero ragazzino negli anni 90 e che
per comprare un disco dovevo prendere un
treno dalla brianza dovevo andare a
milano in un negozio che consideravo la
mecca del disco e in quel momento
comprare quello che avevo sempre sognato
quindi c'era anche una fisicità di
spostamento ora questa cosa non c'è più
poi comprare la musica online puoi
sentirla dove vuoi puoi sentire
all'interno di un centro commerciale e
questa musica spesso non esiste
oggi ha portato alcuni esempi che chiamò
appunto la grande nuova truffa del
rock'n'roll
perché è questa musica ora ha una veste
che ti permette di vendere una cosa che
in realtà esiste già da qualche parte
gratuita
nel 2020 per tantissimi gruppi c'è stata
un'enorme crisi nel fatto che non si
potevano fare i concerti e per startup
musicali come quelle con cui lavoro io
vendere dei dischi fare i concerti è
l'unico modo per sopravvivere
questa piccola etichetta mi ha
contattato per realizzare un packaging
che contenesse 5 cd registrati dal vivo
all'interno di un cinema umbertide
quando mi hanno fatto questa proposta
ho pensato che non avesse alcun senso
nel 2020 realizzare dei cd che comunque
erano già sulle piattaforme musicali
presenti da mesi quindi la mia domanda
era ma perché devo comprare qualcosa che
già esiste non ha assolutamente senso
a meno che non si realizza un packaging
che tenta di far esplodere quelle che
sono i concetti legati a questi a questi
dischi il concetto fondamentale visto
che erano gruppi che erano molto diversi
fra di loro era il fatto che i gruppi
fossero stati registrati in un cinema un
vertice
umbertide devo essere onesta non ho più
pallida idea di dove sia in italia ma il
fatto che fosse un cinema mi ha fatto
venire un'idea di realizzare un
packaging
che non solo contenesse i cinque cd
ma contenesse anche del pop corn e una
busta ovviamente con i dischi
questa esperienza
di mangiare il pop corn esattamente la
stessa cosa che si fa quando si va a
vedere un film quindi ti siedi mangi il
popcorn e vedi il film
questi dischi per me sono totalmente
inutili a livello materico perché nel
momento in cui tu compri questa scatola
stai stai comprando un racconto il
racconto
di quello che c'è dietro la
registrazione di questi dischi
quindi la musica non la stai comprando
stai comprando un esperienza perché dopo
che avrei ricevuto la scatola di pop con
tu probabilmente andrà a raccontarla
alla tua fidanzata un tuo amico andare
in un negozio di dischi per chiedere se
anche loro hanno dei packaging fatti in
questo modo
un secondo esempio
di quest altro piccolo questo piccola
band di cantù e mi ha commissionato di
realizzare i loro sette pollici il 7
pollici e un vinile molto più piccolo
anche qua la soluzione creativa
sicuramente può arrivare da me ma la
base di partenza
è sempre la storia che vuole raccontare
il gruppo la storia qui parla di questo
troll
che potete vedere qua con i suoi denti e
con la sua faccia tutta cupa che sta
inseguendo i componenti nel gruppo
durante la canzone però si scopre che in
realtà i componenti del gruppo sono a
loro volta dei troll per esprimere
questo concetto
la copertina è stata realizzata in modo
che
tirandola fuori dal dal suo busta di
plastica scopriamo che in realtà tutti i
componenti del gruppo sono a loro volta
dei troll
anche in questo caso la musica era già
presente sulle varie piattaforme
musicali ma la persona che le persone
che hanno acquistato questo disco
l'hanno comprato per avere un'esperienza
amplificata perché la materia che è
fatta appunto di in questo caso carta
plastica e inchiostri serve
semplicemente a far esplodere ancora di
più il concetto che il gruppo vuole
esprimere qui stiamo parlando di start
up musicali che hanno dei budget
esattamente come si parla di budget
quando abbiamo parliamo di etichette
discografiche mainstream
però i budget qua sono totalmente
diversi perché qui si parla di budget di
200 euro e non di 200mila euro dove in
quel budget
di fare star tutto la produzione la
creatività l'imbustamento
e per me lavorare con questa startup è
un onore perché spero che durino per
sempre e magari un giorno veramente
possano avere dei budget molto più alti
per anziché commissionarmi un packaging
con dei pop corn di commissionarmi una
nave di kroos per crociere con dentro
dei delfini
un altro esempio è
questo piccolissimo gruppo che doveva
incontrare il maestro edoardo bennato
quando mi hanno chiamato chiamato per
commissionarmi questa copertina mi hanno
detto che ne avevano bisogno soltanto
dieci copie quindi totalmente una follia
10 copie di un cd ma come si fa ad
andare da edoardo bennato con un cd
quando lui ha vissuto diciamo tutta
l'esplosione del vinile negli anni 60 70
allora l'idea è stata innanzitutto di
presentare
il disco esattamente come se fosse un 7
pollici
questo perché siamo sempre nell'ambito
della truffa del rock'n'roll
il disco si apre e sempre grazie al
racconto alla storia dei musicisti alle
loro canzoni
la storia di queste due cover di edoardo
bennato al partono dal suo disco la
torre di babele dove a un certo punto in
questo disco si parla di questo razzo
che sta raggiungendo la luna
e loro pensato ma perché non facciamo a
raggiungere la luna a chi aprirà questo
disco
è anche in questo caso stiamo parlando
di un cd c'è un supporto che ormai
attorno al 2020 non ha nessun senso cioè
siamo proprio fuori tema fuori luogo non
è neanche un supporto bello da vedere
ma anche in questo caso la grafica la
materia e l'esperienza
permette a un cantante famoso come a
edoardo bennato di innamorarsi delle
canzoni di questo gruppo
quello che qua vedete po si può
ricordare per alcuni di voi che hanno
magari la mia età di
quei momenti in cui ti ritrovi al mare
stai pastai passeggiando con i tuoi
genitori e sei davanti a quelle specie
di negozi di giocattoli edicole che
hanno
esposti dei giochi diverso tipo
esattamente impacchettate in questo modo
una banda di carta in alto con un buco
per appenderlo una busta in plastica che
a volte contiene una pistola ad acqua a
volte dei soldatini
quindi qua senza neanche parlare del
tipo di musica che sta facendo senza
neanche farvelo ascoltare grazie alla
magia della grafica possiamo già quasi
sentire la musica perché abbiamo un gran
canyon abbiamo un sole che sta spuntando
abbiamo un cowboy e abbiamo una scritta
che come potete vedere sembra quasi
bruciacchiata rovinata
sul retro del packaging si trovano gli
accordi anche qua tutto arriva
semplicemente dalla musica non in quanto
musica che ha delle note ma perché
nell'interno del della seconda traccia
di questo 7 pollici l'atmosfera è di
vedere zoom i e col che sono due membri
della band che sono sul grand canyon al
tramonto che stanno suonando la loro
canzone malinconica
anche in questo caso stiamo sempre
parlando di un'esperienza perché la
musica realtà è già su spotify è già su
itunes quindi in realtà tu potresti
totalmente far a meno di questo ma
grazie alla carta al packaging e
l'esperienza
l'idea di questo disco esplode
qua avrei una domanda
che cos'è che state vedendo in questo
momento
ecco questo è un cd spezzato a metà di
solito diciamo il common sense dice che
se compri qualcosa si presuppone che la
macchina va il dentifricio la vedenti la
scarpa serve per camminare
questo è nonsense comprare un disco che
è legato a metà comprare un disco che tu
non puoi ascoltare questa è la grande
truffa del rock'n'roll questo gruppo che
si chiamano pei è un gruppo punk un
gruppo punk per chi non lo sapesse il
punk è stato un movimento che alla fine
degli anni settanta esplose a londra e
grazie a diversi gruppi è diventato
veramente un movimento dove per i giochi
eri più giornalisti era semplicemente un
movimento che serve a per distruggere in
realtà era tutta un'altra cosa perché
era distruggere per creare qualcosa di
nuovo
in questo caso questo gruppo mi
commissionò il loro packaging del loro
penso quinto disco
proponendomi di fare un cd probabilmente
perché la loro micro economia non poteva
permettersi di stampare un vinile
anche in quel caso non aveva alcun senso
stampare un cd in 300 copie perchè chi
l'avrebbe comprato
quanti di voi hanno il lettore cd in
macchina
nessuno non ce l'ho anch'io che sono un
grandissimo appassionato di musica
perché molto più facile ascoltarla col
telefono non devo portare in giro niente
o tutti i dischi che voglio e si sentono
da dio
il fatto della gente che dice che il
vinile si sente meglio di quello che c'è
su spotify non è vero al 100 per cento
neanche i genitori aveva uno stereo così
figo per poter sentire
de gregori in maniera eccezionale
quindi per tornare al discorso del cd
spezzato tutto anche qua è partito dal
titolo del disco che è canzoni per gente
che non si fa più che quindi che non si
bacia più quindi un amore spezzato
siccome anche qua non era sufficiente
questa idea che era diciamo venuta
c'è stato un logo che era spezzato a
metà di solito loghi non sono spezzati
li vedi interi e siccome non era ancora
sufficiente sempre grazie a questa
chiamiamola cultura punk che ha spesso
un risvolto 2t or self dove proprio
perché tu non appartiene al mainstream e
vuoi farti le cose da solo ti fai flyer
fotocopiando li fai dei collages 15 a
questo tema della fotocopia la fotocopia
anche un significato brutto per tanti
perché la coppia uguale identica poi
spesso è anche fatta male ma nella
cultura punk la fotocopia è qualcosa di
incredibile
quindi che cosa ho fatto ho preso il
cantante e il bassista
e per il numero necessario delle copie
che avevo bisogno
gli ha fotocopiato
esattamente come quando si fotocopia un
contratto o qualsiasi altra cosa
di solito non si non si fotocopiano gli
esseri umani
questa è la grande truffa del
rock'n'roll
questa è una vera limited edition perché
quando comprate le sneakers che sono in
mille copie in tutto il mondo non state
comprando una limited edition per che
state parlando di mille copie questa è
una limited edition perché esiste solo
questa singola fotocopia non esiste
un'altra uguale perché le pose che hanno
fatto sotto la macchina per fotocopiare
sono tutte uniche questa è la truffa del
rock'n'roll
quello che successe alla fine degli anni
settanta è stato
grazie a malcolm mclaren che era il
manager dei pistols che poi era tutto
collegato anche con la moda con vivienne
westwood con loro negozio sex eccetera
eccetera
sfociò in un disco che si chiama the
great rock and roll swindle
quindi abbiamo iniziato con la nuova
grande truffa del rock'n'roll
per tornare alla grande vecchia truffa
del rock'n'roll
[Applauso]